you know for people who have not seen it
or may not be familiar with it or
bootleg universe i mean in super brief
non-spoilery terms what is guardians of
justice about uh it's uh
on the surface of the deconstruction of
of superheroes told in a in a mixed
media mixed medium format so uh in any
given scene or sequence you'll kind of
oscillate between live action 2d
animation 3d animation claymation pixel
art stop motion um
and within within the vertical of each
of those those mediums especially 2d
animation um
i weave in and out of
a plethora of different styles and
influences
it's so here's the so it's very seamless
though like you know you're jumping from
especially in the first episode you're
jumping from you know 3d to 2d
to live action in seconds and
was that difficult
to
achieve that or did it kind of happen
was it something that you guys had to be
extra careful about in the editing room
and stuff like that
this is how my mind works or rather this
is how my memories work exactly so when
you watch the show you're really just
like kind of jacking into
uh
how my my subconscious right places
together a kaleidoscope of sounds and
images that become uh the narrative of
of my life and my memories um
so kind of from that
from that perspective um
um a lot of it was
intuitive
um
and also you know
hayden how would you describe the show
would you have an easy time describing
it to someone no it's very hard to
describe it's very hard like it's it's
it's a deconstruction of the superhero
meat of the superhero genre
and it's also kind of a direct
commentary like it's using the superhero
genre and appeal to directly confront
actual things that we're facing in the
world in our country yes but kind of
like
a conduit not a conduit i mean it is a
conduit but it's kind of a
way to
use something that everybody loves to
talk about something that everybody
needs to know about and to get people
invested in bigger issues
okay you you totally get it you totally
get it um
it was very hard to
describe what i was trying to do while i
was making it it was actually it was it
was kind of impossible to do it yeah um
and
so
a lot of it was intuitive but then there
were certain things that i realized
through the process of making it or kind
of hypothesized so to speak through the
process of making it so like for example
right had it just been live action and
2d animation
it might have been a little jarring
but
um
you know in the in the beginning you get
a shot of
robo-hitler
yeah you get a claim you get
you get a claymation shot of robo hitler
right yeah okay so claymation's
interesting because it's technically
animation
yeah but it's also live action because
it's real and it's photographed just
like live action right right so the
moment you see that
it it kind of
uh allows a seamless trans uh uh
transition from
live action to
what is this this is animated is it real
stop motion
into into animation so that uh so
claymation ended up being the glue
that uh kind of ties a lot of this
together
that
i didn't realize that but it makes
complete sense how that would be kind of
be
the um middle point between animation
and live action to help smoothen that
strength you know smooth out that
transition
um
so um
you know we
my next question actually really uh fits
into this very nicely but it you know it
plays with a lot of different mediums
and styles visually and just
the whole aesthetic is
a patchwork of really really different i
like styles and ideas that come together
pretty beautifully why why was it so
important to you to do it this way you
know i go back to
what i said earlier which is this is how
my mind processes information yeah so
when i when i look back at you know uh
high school for instance it's not like
i'm seeing live action uh having live
action memories there are moments that
felt super cartoony kind of like mooney
tunes there are moments that felt kind
of
more film noir there are moments that
felt almost like a dance number
right so
so this is this was my attempt to
uh really express how
my mind processes information and also
you know to that point do that effect
um
i love cartoons i love saturday morning
cartoons i don't understand why they
stopped making saturday morning cartoons
you know once you once you get got to a
certain age it was like well you're not
supposed to graduate out of saturday
morning cartoons yeah like like
right
so
so i was i was trying to make a
saturday morning cartoon that was the
right that was the the uh the goal here
the attempt uh so to speak so
so like even on on a performance basis
for the live action stuff
um it was it was intentionally
getting the actors to go a little bigger
go a little louder you know kind of to
emulate so that so that it allowed the
cross pollination between the cartoons
and the live action to work because
right well because you know animation is
an exaggeration of real things and it
bends and distorts things
um
yeah i i really
like what you said about it kind of just
honoring the way that your brain works
in my brain you know in my family we
call it the cartoon brain you know like
somebody mentioned something we're like
oh
i imagine that as a cartoon and it makes
us laugh
so our brains and our memories kind of
naturally medium hop right between
between styles and without us really
being aware of it initially
yeah yeah and and i think this is a
really cool organic way to honor that um
and then
during the process of making it because
i know this has been in the works for a
long time how did it evolve from what
you originally envisioned to what
viewers will see it's not that it
it's not so much that it evolved
i evolved in that uh i realized how bad
of a communicator i was
and
i had to become like better at
communicating uh
you know like
i'm not like from here i'm not from
america i had to like learn things and
then all of a sudden i would say things
to people like
what if it's a dragon
from the 80s
and everyone be like
this isn't a real example of something
hypothetically like that makes complete
sense to me yeah sense to you because
you've got the cartoon brain right but
then yeah but then i realized okay i got
to get hyper specific here otherwise uh
it so so okay what do i mean by the 80s
um so maybe what i mean is okay take a
dragon throw an 80s vhs filter over it
um have it be kind of a scaly lower the
rings photorealistic looking dragon but
take the eyes and make them big so they
feel like pixar eyes and then when you
do the color pass on the dragon's um uh
skin make it like green so it feels a
little bit like a like a 80s saturday
morning cartoon yeah like a sickly green
kind of thing yeah right exactly like
toxic green um
so so to that effect
um this was my original uh intent my
original vision
it was so difficult to convey that
because
again and i
it's
it just kind of asks more and more
questions it's like well how do you know
that this and this is going to cut
together and then what is the language
like why why does it go to
to to to pixel art then why all of a
sudden so then why are you using like
paper cutouts that are that are like
photographed paper cutouts like old
school south park like what is the
intentionality there
right and yeah and there's a
and there's a language go ahead sorry go
ahead no no you go ahead you go in buddy
oh i was just saying that like what i'm
hearing you say
is that it's not that the project
evolved it's that your way of telling it
evolved
it's like your way like you almost kind
of had to rise to meet the way it needed
to be told
exactly exactly
uh exactly
yeah so
that's all exactly no you you hit the
nail on the head right and not and that
um and it just came down to like
communication skills you know describing
we're all good
all the time we're all learning
communication skills all the time the
pandemic has not helped us and done us
any favors in that sense
like you know any of us right
and uh
so yeah it's a lifelong thing it's so i
mean
what was
the hardest stuff to pull off with the
time and budget you had
yeah i guess the easiest the easiest
thing to just say is the is the fight
scenes because we have some like kind of
epic battle battle sequences that are
that that
are way beyond our our budget
threshold one would think right
but
i i've just been doing this for a bit so
i so i knew how to stretch a dollar so
that really wasn't a challenge challenge
per se right but yeah
but it but it added like kind of layers
of complexity when you're like okay
there's gonna be this fight scene and
i'm like do i tell everyone that he's
actually gonna have a cartoon spider on
his back and punching everyone or like
are they gonna all just think i've
completely lost my mind ah
so it was knowing also like when not to
communicate right yeah and and like so
when you're like directing the actors
you want them to go really big you want
them to go really big right because it's
like otherwise if you go too subtle with
it it doesn't it won't cut with the
cartoons
yeah but but like i don't want to tell
them that because then all of a sudden
you know the actors will be like
self-censoring and like
also also also
um you know the whole time i was making
a dark comedy
because the show is ultimately a dark
comedy i don't know if you'd agree with
it it's a dark comedy it has elements of
it yeah definitely absolutely um
and there's like a meta joke of the show
oh it's very self-aware yeah right but
the moment you say comedy to to to to an
actor or to the fit you know then then
all of a sudden there's like a self
self policing that starts happening
um right so it was also i think the
challenge here it wasn't any like one
sequence it wasn't any one medium though
uh though there was about 25 claymation
shots that i wanted but just didn't have
the time to put in
but it wasn't the challenge was knowing
then okay what to communicate when once
i once i realized okay
get better at communicating addy
than it was knowing when to communicate
what to communicate when right
the so
speaking of um i'm going to kind of zero
in on some characters that i saw and the
that are introduced in the first and
they're pivotal to the series
i wanted to talk a bit about marvelous
man i think he
was really interesting to me because
he's essentially superman with severe
ptsd and depression honestly like he's
got he's
very like he's he feels guilty about
sleeping because when he's sleeping
people are dying like he that's the kind
of level of like survivor's guilt that
he's dealing with yes yes and
i think this goes a long way in
humanizing him
as well as in acknowledging that this
world right now can really feel like a
hopeless
emotionally desolate place
i mean because there are some days where
it's just crushing you know you wake up
and you're like
things suck right now like things are
just not fun right now and i think
that's very
that's a validated like it's a way of
kind of validating and acknowledging
that that is the way people are feeling
especially right now
um and and so what aside from that i
mean were there any kinds of themes or
ideas that his role in this story you
hope that it drives home i mean we could
talk about marvelous man if you if you'd
like because i feel like there's a
question there about mara like where did
that come from yeah yeah there's
absolutely i think i think that's what
you're asking me it is yeah here's the
thing um
you know i i've dealt with uh depression
a few times uh in my life like uh once
when i left college what sorry once when
i was leaving college
i was so terrified of like entering the
real world and being stuck behind a
cubicle and
just feeling alone um because i felt
alone um i'm also like
i'm an immigrant
and i felt like an outsider and like an
alien for most of my life
um
and then around 2014
probably started earlier than 2014 but
2014 i i really really really was not in
a good place
and it made no sense and here's the
thing it made no sense right like
career-wise i was crushing it
um
everything on paper was going really
really well but i woke up every day and
i as you said i felt hopeless i felt
uh
just
disillusioned sad um
and i definitely have survivors guilt
from the fact that i'm
from a
ultimately a third world country
um
but i'm not there i get to live and
live here and you know kind of carry out
my dream as a being as being an artist
and
like i i have this voice in my head
saying why you
why you
and
so
my uh my impulse was to kind of dig the
heels in
just keep working
and i was not addressing any of the
issues so
eventually uh in 2014 at the end of 2014
the uh a doctor put me on on a on an
antidepressant called still loft yeah
and
and look at the time i knew like look i
i have to figure out what's causing this
this is going to be a journey to figure
out what's causing this but
zoloft was like a cheat code the moment
i had it like probably like
hours hours later not even minutes hours
later all of a sudden it felt like
wizard of oz like colors all of a sudden
were vibrant again and all of a sudden
um you know it felt like i was in a
musical again
and
that's when i realized like wow
i had been experiencing life as a
prisoner in my own freaking body like
that that's like every waking minute was
excruciating and that's where the that's
where the marvelous man
uh uh
monologue
came from that's that's immediately
that's when
the uh the idea
came to me for
all of us
the that so that really resonates with
me because i also have really struggled
with a lot of this stuff
um i am also autistic and so
there is that that i've got going on all
the time yeah
um and i also you know like i've been on
and off antidepressants my whole life i
mean that's kind of
so when i saw that i i could see i could
feel that there was something personal
there which is why i wanted to ask you
because i think that's
you know a lot of people feel like they
can't get
um they can't get help or they you know
they're afraid to ask for help and
um you know it can be a very isolating
and
um crushing experience
and it's scary because
like you said that the world kind of
is flushed with color once you kind of
get out of it but when you're in it
you're numb you know you're not like you
feel like your emotions have been kind
of dampened
um absolutely absolutely it's every day
you wake up and you're you you're you
know you're just thinking why
like everything is going
fine more or less so why do i feel this
way
and um yeah
i wanted to speak to that because
yeah
and the pandemic has not made this any
easier for a lot it's
uh and the other
the other i guess the other the other
component to this
um and i'm i'm guessing based off of
what you told me about the cartoon brain
uh you experience a experience either
experience what i'm about to say or
experience a version of what i'm about
to say
there's something very overwhelming
about how my mind processes information
because it's like a lot of information
happening at the same time
um
and
when i had a harder time communicating
back in the day
it was terrible because i was like
there's so much happening and i don't
know how to communicate it
um
and
so
i wanted to bring that kind of that that
that chaotic energy
to this story about a world in chaos
right because it's a reflection of
what's going on that like a lot of
people feel that way and and
you know a lot of the stuff that's
happening in the story
is reflective of a lot of the panic that
we're experiencing right now as a world
and as a society it's very resonant and
relevant and
um
i also wanted to kind of to discuss you
know more character names and what they
may mean and reflect or how they came
about
sure i noticed that the the president's
name in the episode one is nicholas
newcomb
and
you know i think that the show does an
excellent job of staying critical of our
country's attitudes and decisions but
still functioning really really well as
a piece of entertainment
um i've always thought as you know i
prefer entertainment that
on a surface level it's extremely
entertaining and if you want to go
deeper you can it's kind of like a kind
of an optional profundity type of thing
where it's like yeah
on a surface level it's immensely
enjoyable and if you want to engage with
it further there's more beneath the
surface for you to sink your teeth into
and i think this is one of those things
and so
what in terms of other types of media
that tackle these types of social and
political issues or any for that matter
what do you think is mainly maybe
lacking or missing and a lot of
um pieces on
kind of our current zeitgeist and what's
going on right now
i don't think there's anything
maybe lacking because you know i i feel
like we're all
i feel like all artists are like
effectively nodes
yeah just we're just nodes of this giant
amoeba that is
um entertainment
so i don't
really feel critical about what anyone
else is is is doing or putting out um
and i i've seen the pendulum kind of
swing every which way uh
so i think that's cool um
i guess what i find odd on a zeitgeist
level
is
it seems like some people
uh feel the need to have opinions on on
things
like
why like why yeah you know what i mean i
don't i don't have a pain like i'm not
i'm not like trying to come up with my
hot take on things yeah especially you
know like
i just don't have opinions on things
where i'm not
some form of an expert and i don't you
know and and i also understand i get
this from the perspective of uh you know
i'm not from any one place i'm not from
any one country um
having just kind of moved around and
been in all these different places you
see that like life is very very very
different and people's points of view
and perspectives and worldviews are very
different depending on like
who they are where they are
socioeconomic factors um
and and we're all kind of not living in
one
cleanly
defined reality
there's all these
kind of sub-realities going on
yeah yeah it's very good
it's very fluid yeah so
so i don't have opinions on a lot of
things because i'm like
i don't assume that my reality is the
right one
right
that's i love that i think that that i
think a lot of people kind of need to
learn how to pick their battles a little
bit better in that sense oh yeah
you know like um
so kind of moving forward when you were
shopping this or did you shop this
around two other
um studio or
studios or streamers or was netflix kind
of your chosen from the get-go um
netflix was
i was not shopped around it was like um
it was uh there was a specific executive
at netflix named larry james um
who was just you know like uh just a i
can't say enough good things
about larry tans or even two larry tans
like i try to write him emails about how
much i love and appreciate him and i
just don't have the book this is where
you get better at communicating i don't
have the the correct vocabulary to
express uh uh how much
larry tans
has done for me uh both uh
done for me professionally
but um but no like
it was just
it was just always netflix they
believed in me
enough to to let me do this yeah
well
you have a good a really solid
pre-existing relationship with them too
with you know between um castlevania and
those other things
and and castlevania is great too just a
side note um and also
um to your point about i i think you're
a very good communicator just for the
record i think you're very good at it i
think that sometimes
like you like things are so overwhelming
that it's
it's like pick one you know like pick
one thing to say because i've got 50
things to say at one time
yeah and then i haven't started talking
yet just say something you blurt
something out um no i i again this is
something i had to work on uh i feel
like i'm much better today but if you go
back and watch like old interviews i'm
literally just staring i'm just
literally staring and they're like addie
addie are you there
are you there and i'm like
sup
yeah all right
it it's
you know
it's something that a lot of like
it's like i said it's a lifelong thing
and so honestly on that same
this is kind of along the same thread
but um
when you're crafting stories and
building characters i mean and this this
is something that i deal with as well as
writers we see multiple creative routes
stretching out in front of us like we're
you know we're standing at a crossroads
and there's a bunch of different ways
that we can move forward
and that path can be very very different
or they can be the same they can be kind
of clumped together but there's a
multiple paths in front of us
and sometimes just picking a road can be
really difficult because it's like i see
value in this road but this one looks
really cool and fun but which one is
going to translate to a better story and
a lot of that is you have a little bit
of faith in yourself and in the project
and a lot of it is like what do i want
to do with it and what do i think people
will enjoy and so
um when you're choosing i guess what i'm
asking is you know when you're choosing
a path to your final product what kinds
of things do you ask yourself
and what elements do you consider well i
think okay so the first the first
question is what is this project in
service of
yeah
so if you're working with a a a
pre-existing uh fan base
okay well then are we servicing that fan
base and the answer is yes
yeah
this project was a person it is a
personal project the end of the day it
is a art house
personal project
coming out of my soul right so this had
to be
authentic to that
but again not everything i do uh is that
and you know sometimes i
zig when i want to zag because i know
hey zigging in this instance
is going to service
the the the end user
yeah
the end user i i love i love using like
like computer tech terminals she
describes some of this stuff it's like
funny because i read this interview
where uh
uh back in the day where uh harrison
ford was talking about like his fans as
his customers
yeah you know and like people are really
outraged like he looks at us as
customers it's like well yeah i mean
harrison ford is a construct
of you know harrison ford is playing
harrison ford in the you know air force
every movie yeah he's in yeah
right
you are literally his customer if you
buy into that it's a customer i
so i feel like you know using words like
that even though it's like kind of like
why you you know it
there's an authenticity to it
it gets your attention for sure it's
also like
and he's not wrong that's technically
correct very technical i think people
just don't like the transactional
nature of it but it's like it kind of is
i mean we're you know like
he's not wrong
um
the
so two more questions for you and we
gotta i gotta wrap up but um what what
is uh your dream project
like just
anything this may be hard to answer
because like that's like i think maybe
we should we should skip that because i
can give you an answer but the answer is
not what you're going to like so i'm
just going to say i've already because
every time i do something it's a dream
project right and i keep knocking it out
like that's the best answer
is it that's the best answer you're
living in your dream i love that like
that's
that's fantastic that's probably the
best answer i've ever heard of that
question
okay so uh so my dream project has uh
you know i keep
doing my dream project because like i'm
not like out there
seeking projects that aren't my dream
project yeah
you know and look
when you have a dream or at least i
believe if you have a dream you put it
out in the universe put it out into the
universe it comes back to you in some
way shape or form agreed yeah so you
know um
i wanted to make a
dark anime
telling of a of like a video game uh
that happened um
um you know this this was like like a
dream project uh guys in guardians of
justice like i also wanted to do
something where i took a portfolio of
intellectual property and
messed with it that's captain laser hawk
that's a that's a dream project uh devil
may cry these are all literally what i'm
saying is i don't engage unless i go
what
part of my dream
is
this
delivering because
if it's part of my dream i can activate
that little kid in me yeah that just
wanted to tell stories about these like
things that the adults thought were
weird and if i can't bring that energy
to it
then i'm being inauthentic
yeah i i think i think that's a really
good like i mean like i said that answer
is fantastic it's probably the best
answer to that question because it's
every you know you're not taking
projects that you're not fully invested
in emotionally
and you know
mentally and everything um so that's it
that's all i got for you addie thank you
so much hayden such a pleasure to talk
to you again